welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the first
episode of crisis on Infinite Earths
dropping last night it's time to dive
into the CW and break down everything
that you need to know about that DC
crossover in this video we're discussing
everything about Supergirl Season 5
episode 9 and all of the major moments
in the first part of the mega event
there's a huge death some nice little
Easter eggs and a lot of teasers for
what could be coming in the future there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to watch the
episode yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of crisis on Infinite Earths
episode 1 in the beginning there was
only one a single infinitude that broke
the darkness filling it with life there
was some good shows some bad well oh man
I can't do this as well as in a writer
basically this introduction of crisis
tells us that every existence has been
multiplied by possibilities across the
multiverse in all realities this is the
multiverse that led to the Age of Heroes
which we see play out in an amazing
montage that shows the arrow bears
characters doing that thing whilst the
crisis slowly begins to invade their
dimensions it's an awesome way to
kickstart the crossover and I love
rewatching some of the major moments
from across the series that reminded us
of just how important it was to save
them all it's breathtaking watching the
red sky spread across all universes and
timelines throughout pretty much every
single version of DC's long and rich
history on screen you can see a callback
to the 1989 Tim Burton Batman universe
which has an appearance by Alexander
Knox who was a reporter in the original
film the 1960s Adam West and Burt Ward
version features a cameo by the latter
and even DC universes Titans one
unfortunately all of these timelines and
universes are plagued by the incoming
destruction and it's unclear whether
these realities will survive the red
wash of death now though these are
seemingly destroyed we do know at the
very least that Titans will be returning
for a third season so to me it's highly
unlikely that this destruction ripped
them apart but only
too much into how this will be changed
in retconned as details are extremely
scarce at the moment but yeah don't
cancel e subscription to DC Universe
just yet
though it was very sad seeing some of
the best versions of Batman potentially
destroyed we haven't got time to mourn
them and we flash over to Supergirl on
earth 38 whose planet is being ravaged
by earthquakes that are ripping across
the entire world this is tracked to a
huge force coming from space that is
going to hit the extra-terrestrial Argo
city and mess at the happy light that
Clark and Lois have created there with
their son Jonathan Cora's mother
Allura also lives there and she manages
to a lower the Kent's to an escape pod
which they used to send baby Jonathan to
earth before disaster strikes this is of
course eerily similar circumstances to
the destruction of Krypton and it's kind
of heartbreaking seeing Supergirl watch
history repeating itself
we then travel to earth 1 and rejoin
Oliver back on the island reminding us
the audience and his daughter how much
he lost over the heirs and how the
island turned him into someone else
though this is a Supergirl episode there
is heavy focus given to Oliver and his
relationship with his child Maya
I bet Disney are fuming that the CW got
in there with the whole Hawkeye in his
door a story before they did but yeah
this kind of sets the tone for the
finale of this entry which I'll give my
theories on in just a bit
Crysis really needed to open with way to
let us know that there would be
consequences
they really hammer home just how
important it is to stop the incoming
threat they pulled together all of the
stops for this and yeah with this
introduction I really got into it Lila
is now the Harbinger and she begins
gathering various heroes together to
unite them to save the multiverse
amongst the ranks of the likes of Oliver
Queen Barry Allen Ray Palmer
Batwoman Sara Lance and Clark and Lois
who she saved on a 38 CW really had to
break out the checkbook
I mean Lyla really had to break out all
of the contacts that she has at her
disposal and she transports them all to
earth 38 to stop the incoming threat at
the request of the monetary they have
all been collected for a mission of the
utmost importance in National City is a
quantum Tower which is capable of
stopping the crisis we also learn that
during the explosion that tore across
the multiverse Jonathan actually was
transported to earth 16 namely the air
21
46 which Sara brainy and Louis go to on
the earth we actually discovered that
Oliver found Jonathan and that this
version of the character has lived a
vastly different life to the one that we
know on earth one on this earth Sara was
lost on the gambit and it is kind of
interesting seeing another version of
the character and the life that he could
have had you just can't comprehend that
sara is alive out there on another
universe and the betrayal is really sad
filled with guilt and regret now I do
kind of wish that we got more focus on
our Oliver from earth one but this is a
nice little emotional beat that also
highlights how the character and actor
could come back in an episode down the
line though the plot is seemingly
portrayed as the thing that we're all
here for though deep down we know the
series is more about wish fulfillment
and which we learn what happened to some
of the characters from other series that
we loved and also what could have been
had things taken a different turn it's
quite fascinating and though the CW ish
aesthetic does get in the way slightly
of the fanservice that were here for at
least for a first episode I was really
happy with how events were unfolding
except for bat woman yeah she sucks I'm
sorry but yeah this is the first time
I've ever seen her and I just wasn't
impressed they kind of cut around her
fight scenes because she doesn't really
seem like she can do them and they also
make a queen of the SJW crowd I'm not on
the whole get won't go broke crowd but I
can kind of see why they call her bat
welcome in now cuz yeah just please let
her act like a normal person
please anyway I'm getting bogged down
here in personal opinion when you
probably just want to know about the
events of the show so Louis brainy and
Sarah bring the baby home and John calls
out to all aliens on earth to ask for a
literal lifeline and means of evacuation
in case a tower defense game that
they're all playing fails it's also lip
service paid to the fact that they're
going to be bringing characters through
the multiverse to safety and seeing if
it's possible this was actually a big
aesthetic of Earth 2 and the futures and
storyline and DC Comics in which masses
of people were displaced onto another
earth and they had to learn to coexist
that's not the main story in that arc
but there's lip service paid to it and I
was happy seeing nods to it year before
the heroes go to defend the tower Korra
and Cal talk about the hope that they
have to save the multiverse it's nice
seeing the two who are pretty much
symbols of hope themselves reminding
each other of all the
good that there is in the universe and
how it's worth fighting for and that the
spirit of Krypton will never die Hawkeye
I mean Oliver passes the mantle to his
daughter and this is also a real
heart-to-heart moment that definitely
feels like the right time to do it
especially with how the episode
concludes we also learn from buried that
he is going to die during the crisis as
was preordained the newspaper that said
Barry would disappear has pretty much
haunted the character his entire life
popping up more times in Tom Cavanagh
has a different character and the
monitor confirmed that this is the way
that things would be all he surprised
and angered by it calls out to the
monitor as it pretty much goes back on
the deal that he made with the character
in Elseworlds
that said both Cara and Barry would
remain unharmed
the monitor sort of speaks in riddles
and yeah you kind of get the feeling
that he's only telling the people things
that they need to hear in order to give
them motivation to do what must be done
so the things that Barry said could
indeed be untrue but I don't want to bet
on it just yet however I am now a lot
more open-minded about the Flash's fate
the monitor does say that that deal was
made for the last encounter but this is
something bigger and more dangerous than
they've ever faced before
so yeah the rules of promises and deals
are all out the window the monitor also
says that he is purposely keeping
secrets about the anti-monitor as it
will cause Olly to prepare for every
possibility the heroes approached the
tower and it looks exactly how it did in
the original crisis on Infinite Earths
graphic novel and a it's a nice callback
which I appreciate it comparing the two
I think this episode does definitely
capture the atmosphere and feel of the
graphic novel quite well even from the
wave wiping out worlds and other
elements of it at the tower shadows
ravage the group and Oliver is mortally
wounded in the skirmish as he refuses to
leave the planet whilst there are still
people there that need to be a back you
a hit even with the backup of Supergirl
Superman and the flash the people of the
world have to enact an escape plan and
Oliver buys the aliens of the planet
enough time to begin moving the
population whilst the portals between
realities are held open with the battle
lost due to overwhelming numbers the
monitor appears and pulls the characters
together including Oliver who as we know
stayed knowing every moment was another
life saved the monitor tells the
characters that Oliver wasn't supposed
to die
this way but that is sacrificed save
billions the pariah appears who we learn
free the anti-monitor from its
confinement and because of this he has
been forced to watch the destruction of
universes over and over this follows the
graphic novels storyline in which the
character appeared just before the
destruction of a world and here his
appearance signals the death of one of
the biggest heroes of the Erebus well
probably the biggest hero of the era
verse because it's named after him
anyway Oliver dies have to believe in
that he saved Cara and Barry but due to
his sacrifice being so early he may have
doomed them to the fate that he tried to
save them from now with the death of the
character I do kind of wish that they'd
slowed down a bit for a moment as I
didn't feel the full impact of it due to
them getting to it as quickly as
possible
I've spoken to some people though that
did say they teared up for it but for me
personally it just kind of went over me
a bit especially as it was something
that's being told would happen for a
couple of months now I was just
expecting a bit more from all the hype
so yeah let me know in the comments
below whether you agree with me or
disagree however I'm not actually 100%
convinced that Olly is indeed dead and
personally I think you will be returning
as the spectre from the DC Universe many
people have inhabited the role of the
character in death I do think the
underwhelming feel here was put in place
because it isn't really the end for the
Green Arrow
he is just changing into a new form that
will allow him to possess new powers and
potentially even defeat the anti-monitor
this is all just a fan theory at the
moment but for me I can't see it
happening especially with the characters
design and the way that these stories
tend to go now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the crossover and
what you want to see in the next couple
of episodes comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of the other
big DC show currently on at the moment
Watchmen which would be linked at the
end we go over everything you need to
know about it and give our thoughts and
what will happen in the future if you
want to come chat to me after the video
that make sure you follow me on twitter
at definition whitey or head over to my
desk squad server which we linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hope they
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2
some blu-ray which contains Black
Panther infinity war and Game Captain
Marvel them all and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video make 'shy subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
crisis in the comments section below but
when it's gonna be chosen on the 15th of
December and the set will be shipped out
from then to ever gets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best not see you next time take care
peace
you